OK, you are not going to hear me say at any
point during the next six and a half months,
which is the lead up to the November presidential
election.
You
are not going to hear me say Joe Biden's got
this.
I'm just not going to do it for two reasons.
Number one, I actually believe it's going
to be a fight to the end.
And I think there's a very good chance Donald
Trump ends up getting himself reelected.
But I'm also not going to say it because I
don't want to risk a single person hearing
me say something like that and deciding that
Joe doesn't need their vote and they can stay
home or vote third party or whatever the case
may be.
There is a path to Trump's reelection that
includes the effects of Corona virus on Democratic
turnout, combined with Trump successfully
using the virus to bamboozle and goad his
base into thinking he did a great job with
the virus.
Plus, Trump doing just enough to keep the
stock market boosted, I think is
the term I would use so that it kind of looks
like the economy is OK even though it's imploding.
But I also am not going to hide the polling
from you.
So that's why I want to talk today.
We have national polls that look good for
Biden.
We have state polls that look very, very mixed
for Joe Biden.
So let's look at some examples, starting with
the general election in the general election.
Hypothetical polls.
Joe Biden is currently winning by an average
of 5.5 points.
Now, this ranges in a tie on Fox News and
Fox News's latest poll all the way up to Biden
leading by 11 in a recent CNN poll.
And everything in between.
And the average is that Biden is up 5.5.
Now, let's think about 2016.
In 2016, the national polling average going
into the election was Hillary up 3.3.
And
Hillary ended up winning nationally by 2.1.
So the polls were close.
They were off by about a point in terms of
the national popular vote.
Of course, we have an electoral college system.
And despite losing the popular vote badly,
Donald Trump won the Electoral College.
Now, currently, Joe Biden at 5.5 points ahead,
has a much bigger lead than Hillary Clinton
did.
Going into the 2020 election.
But remember, the Electoral College system
still would allow Donald Trump to win even
if he lost the popular vote by five and a
half points would be a stretch.
But if Biden wins the popular vote by four,
it's still very possible that Donald Trump
could win the Electoral College.
It would be tough, but it would be doable.
So now let's look at some individual states.
North Carolina is not looking great for Joe
Biden.
There's a recent North
Carolina poll where Trump is seven points
ahead of Joe Biden back in 2016.
Trump won North Carolina by only three.
If Trump doubles his margin of victory in
North Carolina from 2016 to 2020, it's a signal
of very bad things for Joe Biden.
But then we've got some places where it's
looking very bad for Donald Trump.
Arizona is one example.
We talked earlier in the show how Republican
incumbent Senator Martha McSally is losing
by nine to Democratic Senate challenger Mark
Kelly.
Well, Joe Biden is winning by an average of
4.4 and as buttoned by as much as nine in
one poll in Arizona.
That's a state Trump won in 2016.
If Arizona goes from Trump winning by four
to Biden winning by four.
That's an eight point swing.
And it's very, very bad for Donald Trump.
Virginia is another example right now in Virginia.
Biden's
winning by an average of seven and by as much
as 10 in the latest poll.
Hillary only won by five in 2016.
So, again, if Virginia goes from Hillary plus
five to Biden plus seven, eight or nine or
even 10, that is very bad for Trump.
So what's the takeaway?
The takeaway is, no matter what the polls
say, go and vote.
Ask for an absentee ballot if that's what
your state is doing.
Do not sit this one out because it is likely
to be a huge fight.
I was talking over the weekend on Zoom with
a few friends who are very much journalists,
writers, etc.
Many of them feel that November is going to
be a blowout.
They just don't know who's going to win.
The idea being it won't be close either.
Biden will very much pull away with it or
Trump will very
much pull away with it based.
What's going on with coronavirus in the economy?
Up if that's the case, then we're going to
have to fight a very, very hard for it to
be Biden for Biden to be the one who pulls
away.
Of course, predictions are often wrong and
it may well be close and it may come down
to just a couple of states.
So it will be a huge fight.
Anything that makes you think we've got this
is very dangerous thinking.
And I would encourage you to disabuse yourself
of those notions.
Do not get confident.
They have every trick up their sleeve.
And with the wild card of coronavirus and
people possibly staying home to avoid the
virus, anything can happen.
Anything can happen.
Last thought, after seeing Donald Trump this
week, talk about how he has absolute power.
He can tell governors what
to do.
He can demand and enforce that businesses
be reopened after seeing Trump's authoritarian
slide this week.
I am increasingly skeptical that Trump would
leave peacefully if he loses to Biden.
Now, I want to be really careful.
I'm not saying Trump would succeed in not
leaving.
If Biden wins, I just mean it won't be peaceful.
In that Trump will claim it was rigged.
He will claim it was stolen.
He will claim Joe Biden didn't really win.
He may even try to start some kind of legal
challenges.
I do believe he will leave, but I am increasingly
skeptical that Trump will leave.
What I would describe in a peaceful manner,
I do believe he ultimately will leave.
Let me know what you think about that.
We're going to continue coverage of this issue
and others on The David Pakman Show Instagram
page.
That's at David Pakman
show.
Follow me at David Pakman on Instagram.
Later today, I am going to phase two of my
2020 urban garden garden.
I will be tracking and reporting all of it
on my Instagram account at David Pakman.
A nice break of levity from the Corona virus
fiasco.